I am so happy that we are still here
with the incredible John Cena.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much for being who you are.
Ah, man, I just wish everybody would be.
It's tough. It's tough.
Well, any advice,
as a parting word
for people to have the bravery
to be themselves?
'Cause we all have to find it even sometimes every day.
Yeah.
Everybody,
especially nowadays in the realm of social sharing
and motivation.
Everybody's pretty quick to like share quotes
and things.
I specifically use Twitter as a forum,
almost like a journal of philosophy for me.
But there's a reason I publish those quotes
instead of keeping them to myself.
And that's to hold myself accountable
because I want to be the person I tell people that I am.
Mm.
So when I put something out to the universe
that instigates a conversation about philosophy
or tackles an uncomfortable subject,
it makes me accountable.
When I tell you, "I love my wife",
She knows, I love her.
She doesn't need me to tell you,
but it makes me accountable.
And I think that's important
for me as a system of checks and balances
for the rest of the world to keep me in line.
And I just think nowadays we have the freedom of speech,
but we don't have any accountability
a lot of times for that.
So people can tell people
they're a certain way and don't necessarily
have to walk that talk.
And that's hard business
because you have to choose values.
You have to choose beliefs.
You have to define purpose.
And you have to be honest with yourself
on who you are and all of that stuff
is hard work.
And I guess my advice is it's not easy
'cause we all want people to see us
as perfect folks.
Just remember that everybody's flawed.
We all make mistakes
But it's hard.
It's hard work,
but damn it's worth it.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
I think the world of you.
Please give my absolute love to your wife.
Will do.
I don't even know how to add this,
other than to say thank you.
Because these are the kind of conversations
that I could only hope to have on a show like this.
And it takes you to have them.
So, John Cena,
his show Peacemaker is now streaming
only on HBOMax.
It's incredible.
(upbeat music)